La diversité s’applique aussi aux organisations.
Les logiciels peuvent expliquer ce qui a permis aux salariés
de réussir dans le passé.
Et c'est utile, parfois, pour évaluer les salariés.
Mais rappelez-vous que l’environnement change constamment,
les logiciels d'évaluation n’ont aucun moyen de savoir -
et nous non plus -
qui sera utile à l’avenir.
Nous devons donc compléter ce que l’algorithme nous dit
par une intuition,
et en recherchant des personnes avec des origines et des perspectives différentes.
Sixièmement, assurer la sécurité grâce à la redondance et aux compétences humaines.
Pourquoi deux avions 737 Max se sont-ils écrasés ?
On ne sait pas tout encore,
mais nous savons comment éviter de futures tragédies.
Nous avons besoin de plusieurs systèmes indépendants.
Si l'un d'eux tombe en panne, les autres peuvent le remplacer.
Nous avons aussi besoin d’opérateurs qualifiés pour venir à la rescousse,
ce qui suppose une formation continue.
Septièmement, soyez rationnellement extravagant.
Thomas Edison était un pionnier de l'industrie du cinéma,
ainsi que de la technologie de la caméra.
Personne n’a fait plus pour l’efficacité que Thomas Edison.
Mais sa transversalité s'est arrêtée.
Son directeur a embauché un soi-disant ingénieur en efficacité,
qui lui a conseillé d'économiser de l'argent
en utilisant davantage ce qu'il avait déjà tourné
pour diminuer le nombre de prises.
Edison était un génie, mais ne comprenait pas les nouvelles règles du cinéma
ni le fait que l’échec devenait le prix du succès.
Certains grands réalisateurs, comme Erich von Stroheim, étaient l'inverse.
C'étaient de superbes dramaturges - Stroheim était aussi un acteur mémorable.
Mais ils ne savaient pas tenir leurs budgets.
Donc, ce n'était pas durable.
C’est Irving Thalberg, un ancien secrétaire au génie intuitif,
qui a concrétisé cette extravagance rationnelle,
d'abord chez Universal, puis chez MGM,
devenant l'idéal du producteur hollywoodien.
En résumé, pour être vraiment efficace,
nous avons besoin d’une inefficacité optimale.
Le chemin le plus court peut être courbe plutôt qu'en ligne droite.
Charles Darwin l'a compris.
Lorsqu'il rencontrait un problème difficile, il allait marcher en rond,
un chemin en sable qu'il avait réalisé derrière sa maison.
Un chemin productif peut être physique, comme celui de Darwin,
ou virtuel, ou un détour imprévu sur un chemin tout tracé.
Trop d'efficacité peut s'affaiblir.
Mais un peu d'inefficacité inspirée peut la renforcer.
Parfois, la meilleure façon d'avancer est de tourner en rond.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)